and the Houston Chronicle reports most
city schools are open again this morning
after hurricane Harvey but the kid said
yeah we want to go to school before the
storm hit the city schools were
converted to shelters and drop-off sites
for donations but now more than two
hundred and fifteen thousand students
are filling the classrooms Omar
Villafranca visit teachers and children
in the Houston area to see how the start
of school has helped to provide
much-needed relief first year teacher
destiny Riley offered hugs to each of
the returning students last week at
Houston's Kipp sharp breath just the
thing for a group of first graders
looking for a fresh start to their
school year since eliza's we've been
here how important is coming to school
and having something normal for a kid
that a it's paramount what letter goes
right there kids really roll with
routine so having school you know I have
to be here at 7:30 I have to have my
uniform on I have to be ready to go it's
huge for them right now it gives them
something to latch on to did anybody
else lose power at their house raise
your hand the first day back to miss
Riley's class included time for students
to share experiences from the storm when
we sit in a circle and we put all of our
energy in the middle of it they really
grow from that when they're around their
peers they definitely open up because
they feel more comfortable what were you
scared of we want to make sure that
we're really meeting the needs of our
kids
Michelle Bennett is the principal at
Kipp sharp do they kind of help you put
things in perspective even after
something as horrible as this they do
how relationships matter people matter
and being there for one another is
really important well when we go through
these types of disasters tragedies we
really know that we're here for one
another and that's Kip Houston Public
Schools is all about most of Houston's
287 schools reopened on Monday students
returned to Lewis G Lobeck Elementary in
hard-hit Dickinson Texas to that's where
Kelly Trahan teaches third grade all of
this was once upon a time my house and
we're hurricane Harvey nearly destroyed
her home washer and dryer were here
going back to school she
will be a welcome relief for her and her
students I just really think we're gonna
cope together they're gonna want to do
something different than clear out their
house or you know be stuck at home
because their parents are out cleaning
out the house they're gonna want to do
something what did you miss the most the
tireless efforts of school employees
made it possible to reopen Houston area
schools two weeks after Hurricane Harvey
hit what did you miss about school but
most agree it's the students who are
bringing these communities back to
normal
Bratton's how resilient are these kids
you know I'll be honest I was very
surprised at how well that they've
handled this I mean I as a thirty year
old woman was very upset about this but
my six year olds are doing very well for
CBS this morning
Omar Villafranca Houston I'm so happy to
see you guys I'm glad we're all here
there no doubt happy to be their eyes
you love it when a child says what did
you miss most let me go math yeah
they're glad to get back it's normal it
is normal